excuse me I have a warrant for your
arrest let me in your house where
where's your gold if you don't tell me
where your gold is I'm going to take you
to jail I all all right I have a warrant
for your arrest tell me where your
Bitcoin wallet is I don't have any well
we think you do okay go look for it well
how they're not going to find my gold
either of course they can they can of
course they can they can look it's
physical and it exists in well isn't
isn't your Bitcoin stored on something
physical you have like a flash drive or
even if you wrote down your seed phrase
on a piece of paper it's not on a piece
of paper it's in my head oh your whole
your your whole seed phrase is in your
head cuz I understand what it means to
be a sovereign individual and I do not
take that light so then what if you
forget it well I won't well how do you
know well I have I have backup plans
well where where are those I can't tell
you well see well maybe the government
will find that good luck it's at the
bottom of my keys are at the bottom of
the river my keys are at the bottom of
the Florida